direction maintenant le festival de
cannes 22 films brigue la palme d'or
mais il ya d'autres compétitions comme
un certain regard qui donne sa chance
aux jeunes réalisateurs
c'est le cas notamment du chinois dai
sijie qui a présenté un magnifique film
tiré du livre balzac et la petite
tailleuse chinoise un beau succès en
librairie richer tripot gens me
regardaient le festival de cannes c'est
bien sur la croisette mais ce sont aussi
ses multiples villa sur les hauteurs de
la ville où l'on parle également de
cinéma c'est là que l'on retrouve
d'haïti que j'ai un réalisateur
d'origine chinoise qui à l'âge de 17 ans
connu les camps de rééducation de mao
tsé toung pendant dix ans en effet
intellectuelle fils d'intellectuels les
ennemis du peuple furent déportées en
masse dans les rizières et les mines
pour connaître et partager la vie des
prolétaires de son histoire personnelle
d'alger a fait un livre est aujourd'hui
un fil un film qui raconte l'histoire de
deux jeunes gens en rééducation aux
confins du tibet et qu'ils vont trouver
le courage de supporter leur existence
dans la lecture de livres aux étrangers
découvert par hasard un amour de la
lecture qu'ils vont faire partager à une
jeune fille du village qui va ainsi
découvrir et aimer honoré-de-balzac
histoire est universelle
elle aurait pu se situer dans n'importe
quelle situation d'oppression à travers
le monde
la petite tailleuse n'a sans doute pas
tout compris dans balzac mais la lecture
de ses oeuvres l'a conforté dans son
besoin de liberté
cameron
ils pensent pas à traverser sa vie
c'était là il l a vu qu'ils étaient un
autre monde elle pense passer d'un monde
de fiction dans ce monde là les femmes
sont hyper importante et que les hommes
doit tout faire beau essayer plaire aux
femmes
dans les décors somptueux de la chine
montagneuse elle la petite tailleuse va
vivre son histoire d'amour les elle va
aussi nous livre est un formidable
hommage à la littérature et à la
puissance des mots